اعلن مصدر عسكري في الجيش السوداني بمروي
ان الجيش سيطر بالكامل على مطار مروي واسر
عددا كبيرا من الجنود والضباط في المطار
واضاف المصدر ان سيارات الدعم السريع فرت
من المطار من مطار مروي وعلامتها مجموعه
من الاسرى المصريين
معنى من مطار مروي شمال السودان مراسل
الجزيره اسامه سيد احمد اسامه اخبار كثيره
ترد مما يجري في مطار مروي ما الذي استقر
لديك من معلومات حتى الان سيدي احمد
نعم عبد القادر يعني في الساعات الاخيره
اليوم تلقينا كثير من المعلومات وكثير من
البيانات هنا وهناك ليست الحرب كانت بمجرد
وجودها في الميدان المعركه ولكن الحرب
ايضا ما بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني اتخذت منحا مختلفا ااا فيما
يتعلق بحرب البيانات وحرب التصريحات ايضا
يعني معلومات كثيره تحصلنا عليها حول
حول ما يتعلق يعني
مطار مروي الدولي والقاعده الجويه التي
يمتلكها الجيش السوداني في مطار مروي
وكذلك وضعيه
السيطره الكامله على هذا المطار ووجود
القوات داخل هذه داخل مطار مروي الدولي
مصادر في الجيش السوداني اكلت لنا وجود
يعني اكدت لنا ما سمته هروب لسيارات
القوات الدعم السريع من من ساحه من مطار
مروي
ومحيط مطار مروي واتجهت لجهه
غير معلومه ولكن الاهم من ذلك هذه معلومه
اضافيه اكدتها اكدتها لنا مصادر في الجيش
السوداني ذكرت بان اعداد من الجنود
المصريين هم في معيه القوات الدعم السريع
حينما انسحبت سيارات المدججه بخروجا من
مطار مروي الدولي وكذلك
مصادر العسكريه من الجيش السوداني اكدت
لنا الاستيلاء الكامل والسيطره على مطار
مروي وكذلك اسرع اعداد كبيره من الجنود
ومن بينهم ضباط من قوات الدعم السريع هذه
هي المعلومات التي
تاكدت لنا من خلال يعني مع من خلال مصادر
عسكريه من الجيش السوداني اذا نتحدث عن
واقع جديد يعني اكده لنا الجيش السوداني
حول سيطره قوات الجيش على مطار مروي
الدولي وكذلك القاعده الجويه للجيش
السوداني قبل قليل كانت اعمده الدخان
تتصاعد من داخل مطار مروي الدولي وكان
اللافت في هذا الدخان المتصاعد اللهيب من
النيران كان مشتعلا لعده دقائق
ينطفي ما لم نعلم
طبيعه هذه
طبيعه هذا الحريق الذي نشا معه دخان
متصاعد في داخل مطار مروي الدولي ولكن
مصادر تحتاج الى تعضيض وتحتاج الى تاكيد
من عده مصادر اخرى ولكن ما تحصلنا عليه من
مصادر ان طائره داخل مطار الدوله مطار
مروي الدولي قد احترقت ولكن لا ندري اكثر
طبيعه الطبيعه طبيعه الاحتراق هذه الطائره
وما الطريقه التي تم احراق بها الطائره
والمسؤوليه المباشره
للحريق الذي اعطانا هذه الطائره وهل هل هل
هناك فعلا طائره قد احترقت نحتاج طبعا
لمزيد من تعقيدات هذه الاخبار التي تريدنا
تباعا حتى يعني تكون موثقه ولكن الاهم من
الجزيره تحصلت على صور تبين
سيط تبين انسحاب عمليه انسحاب قوات الدعم
السريع وسيارات الدعم السريع من محيط مطار
مروي الدولي
ونؤكد المعلومه كذلك بان المعلومه ذاتها
تحصلنا عليها من مصادر في الجيش السوداني
هنا في
محيط مطار مروي الدولي ان مجموعه من
العسكريين المصريين خرجوا بمعيه قوات
الدعم السريع من مطار مروي الدولي هذه اذا
المعلومات الاخيره فيما يتعلق في اخر
كلامك عن مساله النقل الجنود المصريه فيما
سماه بيان الجيش بنقل باسرع الجنود
المصريه من قبل قوات الدعم السريه من مطار
مروي يمكن التاكيد هذه المعلومه من خلال
ما نقلته من مصادر
نعم من مصادر المصادر العسكريه التابعه
للجيش السوداني اكدت لنا هذه المعلومات
بحسب هذه المصادر واكدتها لنا كذلك مصادر
عسكريه اخرى اي ان هذه المعلومه مؤكده من
اكثر من مصدر عسكري رفيع من الجيش
السوداني طبعا عبد القادر يعني نعيد طبيعه
وجود العسكريين المصريين هنا في مطار مروي
الدولي هذا الوجود كان منذ اكثر من عام او
لنحوي ما يقارب العامين الوجود المصري على
المستوى
مجموعه من الجنود والضباط اغلبهم طيارين
كانوا هنا في مطار مروي الدولي
بتنفيدا لبروتوكول عسكري مشترك ما بين
الجيش السوداني والجيش المصري بروتوكول
تعاون من يعني ايضا
يذهب نحو مسعود من التعاون العسكري
المشترك ما بين الجيش السوداني والجيش
المصري